what's happened to reject nation I'm
Greg Alba I'm John we're gonna watch
this special sneak peek that was sent
over to us that I hear gal gadot is
apparently in or something like that
Ralph breaks the internet yup spoilers
beware for a Greg and jawed hey page for
the day shout out where we do
full-length TV show reactions weekly Q&A
and such but shout out I wanted to give
one to a man named Wyatt who goes by the
name of Commander Josh I looked up your
name Wyatt n it has several meanings it
can mean a war hearty brave strong and
you are a guy who seems to possess close
to zero of these qualities honestly dude
it seems like if anything to have a name
like commander Dodge it's because you're
someone who avoids being a risk-taker
being someone who's willing to put
himself in the face of danger listen
dude I'm here to get in your face right
now and tell you you need to man up you
can't keep avoiding things can't be in
command and dodging all responsibilities
look no sense Wyatts represent no sense
on a serious note though we mean
everything we said since you're going to
study psychology you should know that
what we did was referred to in the text
books as sincerity and now a special
look at Ralph breach the Internet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Matt aha it's pretty that was Meredith
there they broke the fourth wall a
little almost she's from the el bote the
fourth wall he's from DreamWorks
Animation that's right DreamWorks
Animation presents brave yes that is
that is good you know I gotta tell you
though every time I see these Disney
Princesses I'm like there I am that
audience member who's a sucker for
references in meta who just like seeing
this I don't even know what they're even
talking about sometimes I'm just so
caught up in the fact that they're there
on screen and I'm going yeah they're
here and that's why I need sometimes
isn't that sad I've become that guy hey
we all got a nostalgia point that works
for us
oh wait whoa we got clarify something
really quick we know she's from Pixar oh
yeah oh god please and that's a cool
character for a gal gadot to be plain
you know you think you hear a gal gadot
you immediately go to what Wonder Woman
but in this video it's bringing you back
to the roots of where we really got to
know gal gadot the israeli army from
fast and furious you know when she was a
street racer vanellope whither street
racing background not really street
racing but racing and you know wreck-it
Ralph one you know and in this movie
she's gonna do street racing who better
than hot-ass gal gadot from The Fast and
Furious franchise to be teaching her and
Plus Gaga has a sexy voice so I could
listen to that voice all day long does
have a luring voice you play gal girls
voice and Sarah Silverman's voice in the
same is creepy yeah john c reilly oh man
and yeah dude steve brule coming at you
I wonder though if she's gonna play a
very big part in the movie cuz this
movie looks like it's gonna have a
certain amount of like a DD having a lot
of characters I have a lot of different
places to go is it gonna be that big a
deal in the actual movie comes out that
she's there is it just gonna be like a
fun thing for people who know dude these
are a great question there but you know
what I love about this trailer it says
from the studio that brought use utopia
I'm like I'm like we know who Disney is
you know it isn't you know you got you
could have just said the first record
Ralph whatever it doesn't matter you
could you don't need to remind us about
one specific movie when you have the
Disney cattle you own everything now and
you're about to put half of it in like
that's the one you guys represent in
part of the plot is he's searching for a
replacement part to save Penelope's
video game for all we know with the
amazing question you have asked maybe
gal gadot streetracer character shank is
her name Oh
either they're talking about what you
want to do to a man in prison maybe that
will link into somehow I'm still not I'm
still caught up on the fact that it says
much about the title you're gonna Rob
Riggs a nerd they stopped calling it
what about to like want to make it clear
it's a good opportunity for you to
remind people get those DVD sales back
up before the movie draw John's Jeremy
Jones what I'm trying to tell you is it
might be that her character somehow with
the racing and all that either way how
the first one has racing being a very
inclusive element today has an element
that really pertains to the plotline
maybe this plotline racing bringing it
back will help Ralph get the piece I
don't know what I'm saying how rough get
the piece to the videogame to help save
vanilla peas life or vanellope dies at
the end which would be so funny what if
they get to the internet and they just
find out the vanilla peas not compel
with it what if her game is too
primitive they're playing this they go
through the internet like a ps4 and
they're like well we can't go back like
why would we do that
hey John what good question thanks man
doing my bes t guys subscribe to the
channel I'm gonna get a haircut tomorrow
you can click that notification Bell cuz
subscribe buttons are worthless check us
out on patreon cuz subscribe buttons are
worthless you can have a million
subscribers and get five thousand views
on a video isn't that exciting you would
say Ralph has already broken the real
world Internet